GBBO S08E06
I miss the five bakers who've gone.
I'm glad we had a hug
before they left.
It's important to conclude things
properly. Only then can you let go.
Don't you agree, Noel?
I can't talk, I'm a tiger.
What are you two doing?
We're re-enacting The Life Of Pi.
What?  It's pastry week.
Life of pie!
Last time,
puddings were on the menu.
Stacey's determination
finally paid off.
Thank you.  But it was Sophie...
Absolutely delicious.
..who at long last
claimed her first Star Baker title.
And whilst Julia and Liam wobbled...
The jelly just hasn't set.
I just want it to be good!
..we had to say goodbye to James.
Julia was sobbing her eyes out,
and who was comforting her?
Don't get me going. I'm not crying.
He's just such a nice guy.
This week...  Whoa!
Roll on, pastry...
I've just ruined John Lennon's eyes.
..with stunning shortcrust
signatures...
I think it's a bit of a triumph.
..a technical tart...
Gone the wrong way.  It's so jarring.
..and a super-sized Showstopper...
It's an amazing construction.
..that leaves the bakers...
You can't serve up a wonky pie.
..on the verge of collapse.
Don't tell them I did that.
Having a bit of a problem.
I've just realised, actually,
there's only two guys left!
Hm, I don't mind.
Got to represent.
I've been looking forward
to pastry week for ages,
and now it's here,
I'm a little bit anxious.
Pastry can smell fear.
100%.
Morning, bakers.
Welcome to pasty week.
No, it's pastry week.  Is it?
Yeah.  I was looking forward to pasty
week, being a Goth and all that.
Yeah, anyway,
for your signature challenge,
Paul and Prue would like you
to make savoury pies.
Now, the flavour of the filling
is entirely up to you.
You have to make four pies
and the judges would love to see
how you fashion shortcrust.
They have to be
beautifully decorated.
Think designer pies,
the Coco Chanel of shortcrust.
So, you've two and a half hours
to make your four gorgeous pies.
On your marks...  Get set...
Bake!
Right, let's get cracking.
I'm cutting up my butter
as quick as possible.
I want the maximum amount of time
to decorate my pie.
It is quite a challenge. You have
to come up with all this decoration
and on top of that, you have to have
good pastry.
I didn't do it to time
last time I practised it.
They've got to make four individual
savoury pies,
but they must be connected
in some way through the decoration.
It's all about that little bit of
work with the knife and the egg wash
to create something
that looks amazing.
Intricate pastry work takes a lot
of skill and there's a temptation
to keep fiddling around with
these tiny little bits of pastry,
and of course the more you fiddle,
the tougher it gets and it loses
its crumbly deliciousness.
The pies might look amazing,
but when you put that fork in
and put it in your mouth,
it's got to flake,
it's got to taste buttery, and then
you look forward to the filling.
They have to think of not just the
outside, but also the filling, too.
Hello, Yan.  Hello.
So what have you decided to do
for the savoury pie challenge?
The theme for my pie is science and
it's based on British scientists.
OK.  Nerd pie.
This is a nerd pie.  Geek pie.
Stephen Hawking, Charles Darwin,
Alan Turing and Franklin and Crick
will all be honoured
with their own chicken curry pie.
For the Turing pie,
I'm cutting out binary code,
ones and zeros sealing the pie.  Oh!
The DNA helix,
I'm plaiting so it looks like a
DNA helix and then pushing it down.
That decoration alone
would take me a day.
Almost more difficult
than splitting the atom.
Complicated or beautifully simple...
Done.
..every themed signature pie will
require a perfect shortcrust pastry.
Shortcrust is three ingredients -
plain flour, butter, lard.
If you put them together correctly,
you end up with beautiful pastry.
Don't tell it I'm frightened of it.
I've enriched it by two eggs,
with a couple of tablespoons
of water as well.
I've got baking powder in my pastry.
Bucks up a bit in the oven,
which I like.
Get this into a bit of a ball.
If you knead it too much, it will
work the gluten and become tough.
It's a fine balance.
Steven is attempting to perfect
not one shortcrust pastry...
Whoops.
..but two.  I've got two batches
of plain shortcrust,
and this is going to be more for the
decorating on top with an egg yolk.
His second enriched shortcrust will
decorate pies filled with Swedish
meatballs, mashed potatoes
and lingonberry jam,
and all four will join together
in musical harmony.
I'm representing songs
from my favourite band.
Which is?  If I tell you the songs,
do you think you can guess?
OK, go.  Big Love.
Oh.  Storms.  Ah.
Songbird.  Yeah.  And Angel.
Fleetwood Mac.
There we go.
Obviously a fan yourself.
What is it you like about them?
Childhood memories of my mother
cooking and listening
to Fleetwood Mac.
For one baker,
music is just the beginning.
John Lennon is going on the pie,
and Einstein.
That's Shakespeare.  Yeah.
And Amelia Earhart. Portraits of
people who I find inspirational.
Kate's personal Fab Four will be
immortalised atop pies crammed with
a delicious medley of garden
vegetables and fresh herbs.
They look quite intricate.
They are quite.
For ease of cutting them out,
I've made rough moulds
and then I'll emboss them.
I've got little tools I use,
and they keep their shape well
in the oven.
It's amazing.  Thank you.  I'm excited
to see a pastry Lennon.
Me, too!  It's going to be great.
Pastry done.  Now I'm going
to make the filling.
Sausages first.
R squared plus...  I'm not sure
what you're doing but I think
the recipe's a bit complicated.
It's to do with filling
versus pastry.
It's the equation
for the perfect pie.
Is it?  It is, seriously!  I love
that there is such a thing!
There is.  That's made me
really happy.
Stacey's approach
to filling her pie...
Quite a lot of onion in here.
..is a little more homely.
Fry some onions, mincemeat,
pine kernels.
This reminds me of the kind of thing
my grandma Elsie used to cook.
Now I'd love to speak to my grandma.
She'd be so proud I'm on this.
She used to watch it all the time
and I would love to speak to her,
but alas.
Grandma Elsie along with the rest
of Stacey's family
have also inspired
her signature bakes theme.
My theme... Love.
You're going to bring love back in.
Yeah.  I can see red
and paintbrushes.
I thought, what would happen
if I put a bit of colouring
in my egg wash?
You had such a good week last week.
I hope I can continue it
into this week.
I love the idea of the flavours.
Well, we'll see.
Whilst Paul and Prue will expect
incredible flavours...
I would marinate the meat overnight
but I don't have that luxury here,
so I'm going to use a vacuum sealer
so the meat will suck in spices.
..delivering them can come at
a huge cost.
There you go. That's done.
Almost every ingredient the bakers
use in their fillings...
Got the potatoes boiling, got
lingonberries cooking down...
..has the potential to release
shortcrust pastry's nemesis.
I'm towelling off my spinach.
Moisture.  I just want the vegetable
and butter bean to be a bit more
reduced, so not too saucy.
While most are cooking
off their fillings...
hoping to ensure their pastry
stays dry...
Going to get the meatballs done.
..one baker is risking
the raw approach.
I've chosen this filling because
it's something I make for my family,
they love it, so I thought, why not?
Julia's hoping her sausage meat
and stuffing will cook through
as her pastry is baking.
How have you attained this colour?
What have you got in there?
Smoked paprika.  So what's the theme?
I'm making things you can find
on a tree.
So one's going to be fully covered
with leaves.  OK.
Another one's got an acorn.
The third will have a flower and the
fourth one's going to have grapes.
Grapes on a tree?
You can find it on my tree.
The only thing I'm disappointed
about is that you're doing stuff
you can find in trees
and you're not doing a monkey.
Sorry to disappoint you!
Or a sloth.  Or a small boy.
Or Noel.
Or Noel, yeah.  I do live
in a hollowed-out tree.
I'm going to get out of here.
It's got really weird.
See you later!  Thank you!
Even if they've managed to reduce
the moisture in their fillings...
Everything's going to plan so far.
..A shortcrust pie
is still vulnerable.
I'm just lining my tins
with the pastry.
If the rested pastry
is rolled too thick,
there may not be enough
remaining time to bake it correctly.
How long do you have left?
One hour 18.
Cool.  I'm doing my pastry quite thin
to avoid it going soggy.
The right thickness.
To achieve optimum crispness,
Yan has a scientific solution.
I'm sealing it with egg so that
the moisture stays in the pie,
so that it doesn't leak.
But one baker's been even more
cautious than Yan.
I'm just blind baking it with a bit
of egg to firm up the bottom.
Sophie will fill her blind baked
pies with roasted squash,
blue cheese and spinach
and they'll be decorated
to represent the four seasons.
I just have to do what I can.
Every step, I've been fighting
moisture problems the whole time.
Bakers, you have one hour left
before your clever
combining of flour,
water and shortening needs to
taste better than that sounds.
I really need to get this show
on the road here.
Creating elaborate preparations
in shortcrust is as fiddly
as pastry work gets.
I always give myself
difficult things to do.
Once I've decided on an idea,
I can't bring myself to simplify it.
And with four separate designs
to perfect...
Alan Turing, let's go.
..the more time
spent cutting and shaping...
the less time there'll be
to bake the pie itself.
If the four designs were the same,
it wouldn't be so much of a problem,
but it's not.  I need to stick
to my timings.
If I don't, then obviously
I won't get it done. Yeah.
Lee's carefully scheduled
decorations for his sweet potato,
feta and chorizo pies
have been inspired by
the second love of his life.
When I don't bake, I play a lot
of football, video games.  Right.
So one of my patterns
is a remote control.
OK.  And then I've got
a football kit.
What's your team?
Man United.
It's such a shame
you have to leave this week.
If I do go, you know why.
My pastry cases worked well.
Next one.
I've just eaten a bit of your
pastry. You didn't need that bit,
did you?
No, no, no. It was raw, though.
I like raw pastry.
Oh, seriously?  Yeah.  Is that
a Danish thing?  No, I think
it's just me.  OK.
It's going to be Einstein
in a minute,
when I put his facial features
on there.
This is Songbird.
I did need to show some sort of
pastry skill other than cutting
things out.
Darwin, Origin Of Species.
Really running out of time here.
Just 45 minutes remaining.
It's just really fiddly.
I'm now running out of time.
I just want to get
the filling inside.
Big spoon anywhere?
What are you looking for?  This.
It's like Supermarket Sweep!
Pants!  ..then get
the decorations on.
Are you going to be in time?
We might actually make this.
29 minutes?  33.
OK, cool.  It's not really cool.
I'm straining juice because
my filling is a little bit wet.
Normally, you would serve
lingonberry jam on the side,
but I've mixed it in with the mash,
which makes it
an interesting colour.
Would you like some raw meat?
No, it's all right.
I'll fry it up for you.
I'm not a wolf!
I can fry it up for you!
Just eating raw meat out of the back
of the tent!
Oh!
Shakespeare...
OK, space pie, home straight.
It's getting fiddly now.  This
is going to be on top of Big Love.
Nice and careful.
It's not as neat
as I wanted it to be,
but who really knows what
William Shakespeare looks like?
I'll be fine.  I'm doing the
basket weave straight on the pie.
It mis-shaped so much in the moving
of it that it made more sense to do
it straight on the pie.
Whoa.
I tore my code.
I'm running out of time.
Right, bakers, 30 minutes left.
You all right, Noel?
Sorry, I just glazed over.
Bored?  No, no, covered in egg white.
Oh.  Prue did it.
This should be in already.
Little glaze, little shine.
I've got a milk wash,
an egg wash and egg yolk.
It gives it different depths
of browns.
I've put it in a really hot oven,
240 degrees,
to make sure everything's cooked
through.  Time to go in the oven.
Unless all the pies are ready to go
in the oven at the same time...
I'm going.  ..the bakers may not
be able to achieve an even bake
across all four.
See you, babies.
Just going to put that one in.
Putting one in.  I wasn't
going to stagger them all.
I wanted to get them all in at once.
I want that pastry to be cooked.
I want to have at least one cooked.
Still got one more to work on.
Come on, planet.  In she goes.
What's everyone else doing?
Sophie's not got hers in yet.
Pow! Science pie.
I hate rushing.
I hate rushing! It's not me.
I've got all of them in the oven
apart from this one.
Oh, I've just ruined John Lennon's
eyes.
Looks a bit more like Noel Gallagher
because I'm in a rush.
That is going to go in for as long
as I've got and then I'll get them
out right at the last minute.
I don't want John's to look
a bit anaemic.
They might all be anaemic.
Bakers, you have five minutes
to finish your feast for four.
Mine are going to be raw.
What have you got it on?  200.
Whack up the temperature.
I turned it up to 200 instead of
190, which is what I do at home.
Maybe I should have
compromised and allowed them
to cook for a bit longer.
It's definitely a pie.
It's a raw pie.  Cook, you rotters!
It's burning up a bit too much,
so I've put a bit of foil.
Hopefully, it will work.
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
Desperate Dan is on his way
to sample your pies.
He's getting a lift
with his brother, Desperate Ian.
Could you let me know
when there's 30 seconds left?
They've collapsed a bit, but the
designs aren't as I had described.
Cool. Time to take out.
Right, bakers,
that is your pie pit stop.
Please place your pies
at the end of your benches.
One raw pie.
Me, too.  Awesome, dude.
That's totally rad.
I'm so embarrassed.
Why?  They're raw and messy.
Shakespeare, Einstein.
Who's that?  Please don't.
Just don't. Don't.
Now, for the first time in this
year's competition, the bakers
will have their pastry
judged by Paul and Prue.
Hi, Sophie.  Hi, Prue.
Hello, Sophie. Tell us
all about your savoury pies.
So I have the four seasons,
and the filling is a
roasted butternut squash,
spinach and blue cheese.
I love this plaiting
around the outside. That is so neat.
So why didn't you leave it in there
a little bit longer to get
that latticework cooked
a little bit more?
Oh, no, that was intentional.
So that's got a milk wash on it.
Yeah.  And this one?
Oh, maybe that could have done
with a bit longer.
Gosh, that looks good.
That pastry,
it's crispy all the way through.
I think blind baking was
definitely a good choice.
I think it helped.
PRUE:  And that filling looks
perfect.
You've got enough sauce in there to
stick it together, but not
so that it sogs up the pastry.  Yep.
A little bit of saltiness
coming from the blue cheese.
Blue cheese is such a great flavour,
but it hasn't killed the butternut,
it hasn't killed the spinach.
You've got a really good balance.
The whole thing together is
absolutely delicious. Really good.
You've got the right sauce
level as well.
That is a triumph.
Well, thank you very much.
That's a proper Prue pat you got
there.  I get another Prue pat?
LAUGHTER
Congratulations.
I'll just double-check for them.
Just take that with me.
Thank you.  Thank you.
Nice decoration and, actually,
the colours are all fairly even,
except for this one. What happened?
That was the last one in the oven -
it was just a rush at the very end.
Beautifully made.
I think the little hearts
around the edge are absolutely
beautifully done.  OK.
Item one.
Nice bake all the way down.
PRUE:  Perfect. That is very good
pastry.
I have to say, it doesn't look
really pretty.
I mean, there's something quite
upsetting about eating pink mash.
The colour's unfortunate.
STEVEN LAUGHS
It looks a bit like raw pork.
But the flavour's good.
The berries with
the mash are the star of the show.
Nice, bold colour.  Yeah.
I think you could have done with
a little bit less...  OK.
..if I'm honest.
Was it yours that had the, er,
baking powder in it?  Yeah.
You see, I honestly think that's a
mistake, cos it's made it a tiny bit
cakey.
Mm-hmm.  Can't really taste the
sausage meat. It's just paprika -
that's all you're getting,
really, coming through it.
Not your best work.
A little bit disappointed.
Sorry.
I don't think they look good.
No.  I think the plaiting is OK,
but you've lost all
the definition on it as well.
Let's go for, is that Jesus Christ?
Don't rise to the bait, Kate.
Oh, I won't, no.  No.
It's a bit boring.
I mean, it's perfectly pleasant, but
you don't think, "Oh, that's
divine."
And you do have a
couple of soggy bottoms.
I've seen you bake a lot
better than this, Kate.
SHE SIGHS
The expectations are tremendously
high and, really, it does look
a bit of a mess.
and they don't all
look quite evenly-baked.
I was struggling for time so
I thought, "I'm going to get at
"least one pie cooked cos I don't
want to give you
"anything raw to eat."
I think the one we are safest with
is trying this one here, with the
colour.
It's baked at the bottom.  Ooh.
Your pastry is delicious -
buttery, flaky.
I don't think it's the same on the
others.  No.
The chicken is tremendously dry and
over-cooked. The pastry is perfect.
It is pastry week -
just remember that when you...
Yeah, but, and filling as well,
unfortunately. And decoration.
SHE GROANS
And four the same.
Oh, bum.  But besides that...
Sorry, am I allowed to say bum?
Yeah, say it again.
Perfectly OK stuff.
Overall, actually,
I quite like the colour of the pies.
One thing I do like is the dome.
I love that classic dome.
Let's have a quick look at this one.
Oh, it is baked.
OK.
PRUE:  Ooh, that looks good.
Very flaky. Looks a great filling.
Oh, that looks wonderful.
Look at those colours.
That pastry is terrific,
and it's well-seasoned.
I think your textures, between the
chorizo and sweet potato,
is very good - very buttery, flaky
pastry, and it is baked.
I think it's a bit of a triumph.
Thank you.  Well done, Liam.
SANDI: Keep me a bit for lunch.
100%.
Very clever, very neat.
Like the colour, like your designs.
That looks very, very good, indeed.
Well-baked.
PRUE:  It's cooked underneath.
Pastry looks good.
I mean, really well-filled.
A mouthful of pastry and mince is
quite gluey in the mouth,
but the flavour's lovely.
Mince can often give out a lot
of moisture. And, actually, you've
combatted that quite nicely cos
it's got a lovely colour underneath.
And I love that. That's a nice pie
there. That's very clever.
He's just eating it now,
he's just eating.  Good. It's fine.
Reminds me of me nan.
SANDI LAUGHS
It's like a proper northern pie.
Very well done.  Thank you.
Thank you.
'The pies were actually baked,
and that was a result.'
How that happened, someone was
obviously looking down on me,
sorting me right out.
Decent. Decent.
I found 30
minutes from somewhere.
I have no idea how I did manage that
because I was 30 minutes
over in practice.
So, shows what I can do when I
actually pay attention to something.
I've never, ever been called
boring before, so that's a first.
Ugh.
The pie was so good at home.
Now, people will think that
I can't make pie.
I can. I can so make pie.
The bakers' next challenge is
a mystery wrapped in pastry.
Right, bakers, I have to tell you
that your Technical Challenge
has been
set for you by Paul.
Paul, have you got any
advice before you leave the tent?
Read it carefully before you start.
Go now, and never darken our
tea towels again.
Until judging, obviously.
For your Technical Challenge,
Paul would like you to tackle
rough-puff pastry...  Of course.
..and make for us pasteis de nata.
Basically, Portuguese tarts.
You need to make 12
of the beauties with a crispy,
firm base and a perfectly-set,
smooth custard.
You've got two hours to
make your Portuguese tarts,
BOTH:  On your marks, get set, bake.
The bakers all have identical
ingredients
and Paul's pared-down recipe.
If I make custard tarts,
I've always done it with shortcrust.
I've never done it with rough-puff.
Have I had a Portuguese tart?
Of course, I have.
I know the pastry -
it's like a spiral.
Yan, how do you say it, babe?
Pasteis de nata.
Pasteis de nata?
ENGLISH ACCENT: "Pastiche de Nata."
Egg tart, love.
So, Paul, why have you set pastiche
de Nata as a Technical Challenge?
It's one of my favourite
bakes of all time.
Where do things go wrong?
From the very beginning.
They've got to understand
the philosophy of how a
rough-puff pastry actually works.
You're producing a flat dough with
butter in, and on, and folding it
and chilling it and folding it
again, which pushes the layers apart
which creates this
beautiful, flaky pastry.
Moving on to the filling,
nata meaning cream.
So, although it hasn't got cream in,
the texture is very much
like cream - silky and smooth.
Can we eat one?  You certainly can.
But look at the base.
You have that characteristic
swirl around the bottom
but when you bite in to them...
Go on, then.
Crisp pastry on the outside,
slightly chewy in the middle.
Mm-hmm.  It's really heaven.
Now, they are worth the calories.
They are worth the calories.
It says, "Make the rough-puff pastry
dough using the chilled butter."
I've never made rough-puff,
so this will be a challenge.
I'm just rubbing the chilled
butter into the flour.
Then, I am going to
add in drops of ice-cold water.
Everything on this is supposed to
be as cold as possible,
so just trying to keep my hands out
of the equation as much as I can.
Just going to try and get the
right consistency.
It feels a bit dry.
STEVEN: "Roll out the pastry and
half the frozen butter over one
turn."
So, that, we are going
to add the other half
and we're going to bring it back
over like that.
Forgotten how to fold pastry.
So, it's like you fold it,
and then you turn it,
and then you do it again...I think.
Give it half a turn,
do the same thing again
and that creates the layers
between the pastry and the butter.
so it puffs up,
crispy and flaky.
I have no clue if this is right.
And chill.
I'm going
to make a start on the custard now.
"Heat the milk and the flour
in the pan, infusing the cinnamon
"and pared lemon."
SANDI: Are you enjoying making it?
No, not really.
I've never made rough-puff before.
I've never made this type of custard
before. I don't know what I'm
doing.
So other than that you have no idea
what you are doing, it's going well?
Yeah.  Great.  It's all under control.
OK, I am going to go and see
if I can, erm,
put you on some dating websites.
Seriously, she's got all the
qualities that you're looking for.
She has no idea what she's doing.
I am going to turn my pastry
over again.
STEVEN:  So this is after the first
chill,
so I am just going to roll it
out a little bit.
Have you ever been to Portugal?
No, I've actually never been to
Portugal. Have you?
Quite beautiful-looking people.
I didn't expect it. "Quite
beautiful-looking...people."
All the people there are really
beautiful. I'd never felt
so ugly in all my life.
"Add the sugar syrup to the milk
mixture." So pour that into there.
"Combine with the egg yolks."
So much whisking.
STEVEN:  With custard, you slowly add
hot milk to egg yolks.
If you don't, you'll curdle the
eggs,
so I am just doing it as
slowly as possible.
I have never made a custard with
an actual whisker,
so I'm not going to really start.
It's looking OK. I don't know
if it's going to bake all right.
"Roll the pastry dough to a
rectangle then roll in to a log."
How thick a log?
I don't think there's any hidden
messages in there.
I'm just going to go with what
I know.
Right, so, that way.
How many do you have to make -
12?
SHE EXHALES SLOWLY
12 pieces out of that.
I think I see layers.
Cos it kind of forms a nice
little laminated kind of wheel.
I'm very confused.
Doesn't look a very good disc,
does it?
Oh, sugar.
I just realised that
I rolled it the wrong way.
There won't be as much rolls.
You're right.
HE SIGHS
We've gone the wrong way.
I've got the same problem.
HE GROANS
It's so jarring.
That is so annoying.
I just thought it was so obvious to
roll it longways to get it wider.
But, no, it should have been the
other way -
the short way and thinner,
with bigger discs.
So, now, they're
not going to puff up as much.
Now, we should all try
and keep up with the recommended
five pastries a day
but these Portuguese tarts are borne
of a different habit altogether.
And it was here at the magnificent
Monastery of Jeronimos
in Belem outside Lisbon
that a few religious folks with
frankly time
and egg yolks on their hands created
one of Portugal's most famous bakes
- the great pasteis de nata.
I want to find out exactly how we
got from monks and nuns to tarts.
In Portugal
at the time, there were an awful
lot of monasteries and convents.
And you had a lot of priests
and a lot of nuns,
and they had wimples and vestments.
White clothes.  There's always white
stuff, and it needs starching.
And, in those days,
they used egg whites.
So a lot of yolks left over.
What are you going to do with them?
Using those spare yolks,
the monks of Jeronimos
created their iconic custard tart.
And, 180 years later,
they are
still being made to the same recipe.
Can you show me how to do it?
Just go for constant round movement,
always the same direction,
and don't worry about pressing
it on the top.
Spreading the layers evenly up
the side of the tin is key to
creating the perfect flaky
pastry case.
So I'm going to push, turn.
No, no, no.  No, other way.
It's hard.  It's hard.  Takes a lot of
practice.
They are famous all over the world -
what do you think it is about them?
Being able to keep the original
recipe, and the dough is
actually a little bit salty, I think
it's this contrast between
being sweet and salty that makes it
so special and so different.
It looks like the simplest movement,
but it's a piece of art to make it.
Is it getting better?  It's better.
There you go.
NOEL:  Bakers, you have one hour
left.
And I've got a little Portuguese
fact for you.
Portuguese footballer Cristiano
Ronaldo once fired a custard tart
out of a bazooka, stunning
a chaffinch in flight.
LAUGHTER
So bear that in mind as you
are making your tarts.
It says, "Place each disc in to
a muffin tin."
"With your fingers,
line the bottom and the sides."
If the bakers over-handle
their rough-puff, they'll crush
the delicate layers they worked
so hard to build up in the pastry.
HE SIGHS
I am not really happy right now
because it just ripped.
Oh, God.
They are big tins and not much
pastry,
so I'm just trying to make it
stretch a bit.
That's not right. If I had a smaller
tin, I'd be all right.
YAN:  Oh, yeah, baby!
I don't know whether it's supposed
to be like that or not.
They look all right, don't they?  I
think, yeah, I'd like them a bit
neater.
They look quite different to
some of the other bakers'.
Really?
Some people have got smaller cases.
Well, I don't know who is
doing it right.  Who knows?
I don't know whether I should
make them wider, or just do it.
My pastry is absolutely rank.
OK, so I am filling my tarts now.
Custard consistency is key.
Too thick now, and
when it bakes it will never achieve
the silky-smooth
texture of a pasteis de nata.
I have done my custard -
it's definitely right.
It's so foamy. I whisked the eggs
obviously too much.
Do not drop this, Steven.
I am going in.
I'll put them
on for 18 minutes.
12 minutes...I think.
I think they should be kind of set
on top,
and, like, brown, I think.
BUTTONS BEEP
Start it off with ten,
and then check it all the time.
Still wet.
They're a bit puffy at the side.
I don't know what
they're meant to look like.
'Two of them look fully-covered,
'but now they kind of sunk.'
OK, absolute disaster.
They need to be spread out.
CLATTERING
I'm having a bit of a problem.
Right, bakers, five minutes
before you must present your
pasteis de nata.
They are not ready yet.  No.
Are these done?
Yeah. Well, sort of - I just
need to put some colour on them.
OK. How do you do that?
With a little ssh?  Wow.
Little flame-thrower?
I'm not sure...  Bunsen burner?
..I don't think so.
I'm just going to put it
under the grill.  Oh, OK.
I wish they were browner on top.
They're a bit burnt.
They don't look too happy do they,
my pathetic little natas?
They are meant to be browned
a little bit on top - you know
like burnt spots?
I think they have got dark
patches on them.
Pastry is quite crisp.
I really don't know
whether the pastry is done.
Yeah, there's really good
lamination on it, which is awesome.
You have one minute to
finish your tarts off.
Do you know, in another context
that might really sound weird.
I'm playing chicken.
I think it's turned to
scramble the egg. God.
I'm not sure how they're supposed
to look. I just don't know.
They look like the real thing, let's
hope they taste like the real thing.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your pasteis de nata
up to the table.
KATE:  Mine look so burnt.
Paul and Prue will be looking
for perfectly crisp puff pastry
cases with a swirl on the bottom,
filled with smooth, creamy,
lightly-mottled custard.
Shall we get started
on this one, then, Prue?
They are about the right colour.
So this has got a swirl -
it looks quite well-baked as well.
Custard is a little solider
than I'd expect.
Yeah, it's not as light
as it could be, but it is creamy.
And, actually, the shells are OK.
Moving on to number two. What we
have there are chocolate cupcakes.
With a swirl, sort of.
The pastry case isn't too bad.
But that top, you can
taste the burntness coming from it.
Number three.
This is a bit irregular, actually.
The colouring there is not too bad.
My issue is there has been no
lamination on that.
There is no swirl there, either,
underneath.
Huge amounts of issues here.
That's half the depth
it should be. There is a swirl.
Where has all
the rest of the custard gone?
It doesn't look like a pasteis de
nata at all, does it?
The flavour is surprisingly OK.
These shells look much better.
We have the characteristic
swirl underneath.
That's good.
They are a little bit better,
but the custard is quite solid.
I've got great hopes for this one,
cos it looks good.
There is a swirl.
The overall feel is good.
That custard looks to me perfect -
it's creamy, it's got the blotches
on it.
They are pretty good.
The pastry is good,
the custard is particularly good.
Right, last one. This looks
more like shortcrust than flaky.
You can hardly see the swirl at all.
Very tough pastry.
Oh.  Not good.
So who has achieved Portuguese
pasteis de nata perfection?
In seventh spot is this one -
whose is this?
Julia, it's like shortcrust pastry.
In sixth place, this one here.
No-one owning up?
Stacey.
This is not your finest hour.
Kate is fifth, Liam fourth,
and Steven is third.
In second place, we have this one.
Sophie, the swirl is perfect,
the pastry is properly cooked.
It's not a bad pasteis de nata.
That leaves number one.
APPLAUSE
Thank you.
Custard was excellent.
You managed to get the beautiful
mottle on the top,
and the whole thing tasted
very nice.
'I'm totally relieved.'
That takes
a little bit of the edge off,
and now I know that my pie is...
My pie is good.
Not top three, not bottom three.
The plan was to go
kind of higher every week
and I seem to do this all the time.
So I kind of need to be more
consistent, kind of grow a bit more.
All to play for tomorrow, I guess.
One pastry challenge remains,
one more chance for the bakers
to earn their place in the tent
next week.
Who do you think is in line
for Star Baker?  I think Liam.
His pie filling was delicious.
I think Sophie has done well.
The butternut squash and the
blue cheese together was delicious,
and the pastry was gorgeous.
So, going into the showstopper,
who's got to pull out all the stops?
Definitely Julia.
Julia was last in Technical,
she struggled with the savoury pie.
She has not had a good week
so she has got to do
something amazing to save herself.
Who else is in trouble?
I'd say Kate.
Kate, actually, has been struggling
the last few weeks.
She is just limping through
week to week.
I'm actually going to throw Stacey
in the mix as well.
Although I did love her savoury pie,
to come sixth in the Technical
will always put you
into a bit of trouble.
If you have a terrible Showstopper,
you're in trouble.
Morning, bakers. Welcome to
your final pastry challenge.
For your Showstopper today,
Prue and Paul would like you to make
a hand-raised pie
with a hot water crust pastry case.
Hot water crust involves water
and it's a bit crusty.
You've got no idea, have you?
No.  No.
The filling is entirely up to you,
but we want one family-sized
pie that can be shared later on,
you know, by four greedy people.
You have four hours
to make your hand-raised pie.
On your marks.  Get set.  Bake!
Right.
'The bakers must start
by making a hot water crust pastry.'
So I'm just melting my lard
with some water.
'The high fat content in this dough
means that it should be able
'to hold its shape in the oven
without a mould.'
There's something impressive, isn't
there, about a hand-raised pie?
You go , "Yeah, I hand raised it."
Like you brought it up or something.
Paid for its tuition.
They've got to make a family-sized,
hand-raised pie.
It has to be savoury.
They could choose
a vegetarian option,
they could choose a meat option,
but we want it topped
with glazed fruit,
and it must complement
the filling inside.
What I'm looking for is
really good powerful flavours,
and when you cut a slice of the pie,
the whole thing must hold together
like a slice of cake.
The traditional hand-raised pie
uses, essentially, a dolly
or a mould which you shape
your hot water crust pastry round
to create the overall shape
of the pie.
Oh, it's the lard.
It stinks like hell.
I've just got flour and butter
in here and lard.
The idea is
that it's more watertight
so it can keep in juices
without getting too soggy.
Sophie's watertight piecrust will be
topped with forest fruits
and filled with venison, rabbit,
wild boar and guinea fowl.
One of the big things with
a game pie is when you cut them
the amount of liquid that comes out
of the bottom of it is horrendous.
Yeah.  How are you combating that?
I have a little syringe
so at least if I extract the juice
then it's moist
without it flooding out.  Yeah.
Hand-raised pies,
the concept is simple,
but it's got to not look like
it was made in a factory,
but, you know,
you can't serve up a wonky pie.
Steven's pie will be full of
the flavours of a Christmas dinner
and for a touch of festive bling,
he'll be topping it with
glazed, glittery cranberries.
I was going to try and be smart
and put a mini Santa in or something
but, no.
No, Steven, curb your design
this week.
This is all about the pastry.
Most of the bakers are sticking to
the traditional
hot water crust recipe.
Look at that.
But Liam and Kate are
spicing things up.
I'm making turmeric pastry.
I don't know
if it will be that great,
but it should be all right.
I'm doing a turmeric hot water crust
and inside I am doing
a potato and onion curry.
Floats my boat.
Topped with mango and chilli,
Kate's simple potato curry pie
will be encased in
a thin, crisp pastry.
Now, the hot water crust pastry,
you're using this as your mould.
This, yeah.  That is a very big
mould. Have you got enough pastry?
Yes, cos I don't like
really, really thick pastry anyway,
so I'm going to roll it
relatively thin.
I'm looking forward to this,
especially with the mango and chilli
on the top as well.
I'm only worried about whether
that pastry will be a bit too thin.
So I'm going to start
raising my pie.
I'm going to shake the pastry around
upside down,
I'm going to roll it out on the top,
bring it around the sides
to the bottom.
'Because the pies must bake
without their moulds,
'ensuring the walls have
an even thickness is crucial.'
If they are too thin at the base,
that is when it will collapse.
'Hand-raised pies have been made
this way for hundreds of years,
'but 19-year-old Liam is
doing it his own way.'
I'm using a cake tin.
I originally formed it around it,
but it didn't work for me.
So your binding the inside?  Mm-hm.
What's your problem, Hollywood?
What is it?
Traditionally it is on the outside.
Not the inside.
Ignore his face, Liam. Look away.
Look away from his face.
Liam's take on a hand-raised pie is
also a tribute
to his nan's Sunday dinners.
He will fill his pie crust
with curried goat
and top it with
a mango and avocado salsa.
So, do I take the risk of doing it
the traditional way...
..to make boss man happy?
Or do I stick to my guns...
..and do what I've done at home?
Hmm.
'But Liam is not the only baker
who's crust could land them
in hot water.
So I've read in books,
hand-raised pies,
and they mould it on the inside
so I didn't know what to believe.
So I chose the easiest option,
as you do.
Liam, I am doing it exactly
the same way as Liam though.
I have no idea what to do.  Outside.
I've never actually tried doing it
that way.
Never.  Just change it.
I've never tried it.  Oh.  Never.
I think I'm going to do it.
So I'm going to give myself
a challenge.
If it works, it'll work.
I'm just going to go and do it.
I'm not going to change it
because...
What's the point?
Shall I redo it?
Are you tempted to redo it?
Yeah, cos they might mark me down
otherwise.
But what I don't want is
to serve a raw pie.  Right.
So I'm going to go with this one
and serve it and take the hit.
Yan's hoping to distract the judges
with her pie's colourful
chequerboard interior
and her elaborate fruit topping.
I know this one works
because I'd done it several times.
Fingers crossed.
Now it's all kind of going OK.
I'm just going to bang it
in the freezer for a little bit.
Yeah, it looks all right.
Slam it in the freezer
to firm it up.
'Whilst the pie crusts chill...'
Right, meat time.
'..the baker's move on
to their fillings.'
Whoa!  I just lost half of my hair.
This is a roux-based sauce
so very thick sauce.
I'm adding blue cheese
for the flavour.
When you cut into it,
it kind of holds it all together.
Julia's blue cheese sauce will bind
her flavour-packed fillings
which she will layer
into her pie crust
before removing the mould.
I feel a bit nervous, obviously,
because I do feel the pressure.
But at the same time, I feel good.
I will just try and enjoy what I do.
And hopefully it all will
go to plan.
I'm making a meat-free pie.
So it's got a layer of paneer
and then a layer of curry
and then a layer of eggs.
Sometimes it's nice just to have
something without meat for a change.
Stacey will set off the flavours
of her lentil curry filling
with glazed mango cubes.
Have you practised this at home?
I have.
I did two on Friday and one was
like ugh,
and the other one standing proud
so I'm hopefully going to do
a standing proud one today.
One hour of the bake has
already gone.
And whilst Yan and Julia are
filling their pies
before removing them
from the mould...
Not the most appetising of looks,
I apologise.
..the other bakers...
It's going to come out.
..are about to find out
if they have successfully
hand-raised their pies.
I'm going to try and take it off the
mould which is the difficult bit.
I don't like this.
How do I get this out?
It's got holes in the bottom cos if
you don't have holes in the bottom,
it creates a vacuum and
nothing's coming out.
I'm a crust whisperer.
I'll talk that out.
Come on. Come on, fella.
Just...
Why isn't it coming off?
Are you allowed to do this?
Stop me. I dare you.
There you go.  Oh, yes! Thank you.
It's happening. Come on.
There you go.
What's the baking handshake?
What was it?
This one and then this.  Solid.
Me and Paul do that
when you're not looking.  Is it?
Try and keep up with the youth.
Completely cracking.
Hurry up and fill the thing.
I have put some spinach leaves,
and then on the top,
it's the rest of the meets.
They didn't want to
layer it too much,
I didn't want it to be too fussy,
but when you cut it open,
it's got to look pretty.
Everyone else is
doing, like, mad layers and stuff
and I'm just, like, potato.
I've just realised something
really bad.
There's a bit of baking
parchment in the bottom.
I'm going to put my lid on
and crimp it in.
I've got to sort myself out now
cos I've got to get this
in the oven.
Not good.
At all.
Bakers, you are halfway through
your hand-raised pie
Showstopper Challenge.
For Julia and Yan, it's
the moment of truth.
Doesn't come off.
Don't tell them I did that!
I'm really scared to take it out of
the mould.
OK, do you need help?  Yeah.
This wrap that I put around the edge
is to hold it,
just for the first half an hour
whilst that pastry sets.
What do you do at home?
I use a palette knife.
What are you doing?
Um, trying to patch up a crack.
Patching up your crack?
I've got a big crack.
Ow!  That's going to leak everywhere.
Leakage?  Leaky crack, it's really
not a good thing.
NOEL LAUGHS
If you take that off, would it be
easy just to pull it apart or...?
Take what off?  This...this is
holding it together, right?
Oh, my God. I can't believe I'm so
stupid.
Got to get it in the oven.
That's probably going to go in for
about an hour, actually.
There's raw meat in there, but I
don't want it to be dried out.
That's the problem with turkey.
I'm just putting a bit of foil
cos I don't want the sort of top
of the meat to burn
cos there's no lid,
so just trying to keep a bit of
moisture in.
My aim was to sort of go for, like,
erm, straight on one side
and kind of caved in on the
other side
with, like, a floppy kind of look.
That's my aim. Yeah.
I think they'll buy that.
I am syringing off the juices from
the pie
cos there's a lot of it.
Let's get glazing.
I'm making my mango
and avocado salsa.
Mango, avocado, pomegranate,
red onions, lime juice, lime zest.
Peaches go with pork.
Apricots go with pork.
Figs go with pork. I quite enjoy a
bit of fruit.
Makes you feel not so guilty
when you're having a
massive, great, big fatty pie.
This is for the topping.
Are you OK? You seem fine.
Yeah, fine. You know me.
I'm not a big one with public
displays of emotion.
One day you'll crack, though,
you know that?
And burn the tent to the ground!
COCKNEY ACCENT:  Bakers, you've got
one hour left.
Get your bleedin' pies out the oven!
Have you got Russell Brand's
underpants on?
I'm going to take
my baking paper off
and hope that it's going to hold
its shape.
It held. Good.
I'm pleased with that.
It's still soggy. God.
It's a disaster.
All...everything about it.
But maybe they won't notice.
That...that could happen.
Paul could suddenly...turn into
a different person.
Yes.
All right, get in there.
I want to get somewhere between
70 and 74.
I'll go up to 74 cos
there's meat in it.
63. Got to get up to...
..70.
It's quite quick to cook.
Ugh, I don't like this bit.
It's cooking nicely.
I reckon it's got another ten
minutes left.
It looks done, but it's the
temperature at the top.
It's just infuriating.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes to
finish hand-raising those pies.
I'll give it another minute
for luck.
My pie is all right.
It's not too bad.
Pie is cooked. Yeah.
It's looking cooked.
One side is all right.
Meh!
I'm going to give it another
ten minutes.
If it's not done, they can't eat it.
Whacked it up, the lot,
so just got to wait.
It looks beautiful!
The top cracked a little bit.
Just hope it's going to be fine
because haven't got much time left.
So, what have you got to do next?
So, I'm just going to cover it
with the fruit.
It's a shimmer spray.
And then...
make it rain.
Could not be serving something
without bit of camp in it.
Wow, that's gorgeous.
That's awesome.
Very cool.
I can't put my topping on
cos it's not flat.
It keeps falling off!
Five minutes.
One minute heating?
To the last, almost
to the last minute.
Ah, it's cooked!
You've got one minute left.
One minute.
Don't want to have to do to this
when it's warm, but...
Do you want me to help?
Could you take some of these and
just, like...?  Shove them on.
If you can, yeah.
Right, that is the end of your
Showstopper Challenge.
Absolute disaster-looking thing.
The bakers and their
hand-raised pies
must now face the judgment of
Paul and Prue.
Did everything go to plan?
I'll know when you cut it open!
Takes a long time to get that even,
smooth outside.
I mean, it is beautifully done.
Well done.
Yes.
To do that much game and not get any
liquid out of there,
is very, very good.
I think it's an amazing
construction
and I love all the flavours.
The forest fruits cut through that,
that tartness really cuts through,
but it's that pastry, it's too thick
on the side,
and so you've got that raw bit of
hot water crust running through it.
I think it looks great.
Oh, look at that. Doesn't that
look perfect?
The pastry's thin,
but it's held well.
I think the flavour is lovely.
And I think it looks pretty.
Love that.  Do you?
Yeah. Absolutely.
The coolness of the mango with the
curry just works.
Very clever.  Thank you.
It does look a bit of a mess.
It certainly looks home-made.
It probably should have been a bit
more professional-looking.
One other thing I kind of have to
tell you...
..I'm afraid there's a bit of
baking parchment in the bottom.
Like a surprise?  No, it's actually
in the pie, isn't it?
Yeah, it's actually in the pie.
When I took it out of the mould,
it was falling apart so I filled it
up really quickly
and the parchment circle is still
in there.
I'm so sorry.
I think if you were having this
as a meal, it would work.
You've made a dish which tastes good
and haven't considered the
hot water crust pastry.  Yep.
Look how straight those sides are.
It's neat, it's got a
lovely colour on it.
It looks really moist and
attractive.
It does look good.
You know...overall, it's a
bit bland.
The stuffing and the turkey almost
taste identical.
The Brussels sprouts are
almost immaterial.
It's a bit of a let-down
on the flavour.
Now, this one was done inside
the tin?
Mm-hm.  Is that right?  Yep.
I think it looks all right.
The little bit of crimping looks
quite nice as well,
but I'm dying to see that
chequerboard inside.
OK.  Oh, that does look good.
Wow.  Very nice.
It's quite stunning.
The pastry is crispy.
It's golden. Nice, rich flavour to
it as well.
All the sausage meats
taste different,
and the fruit works with it.
I think it's absolutely wonderful.
Yes!
Could have been much neater...  Yeah.
..where the lid meets the sides,
and they look a bit sad,
sitting on the top.
Now, you did this in the tin.  Yeah.
I don't think the asparagus works.
It's all been in the oven too long
cos the chicken is dry
and the asparagus is overcooked.
On the other hand, the
pastry is undercooked.
My conscience kicked in,
so I ended up doing it the
traditional way of using the outside
of the cake tin.
Does your conscience have steely
blue eyes and a silver-grey beard?
LAUGHTER
Right.
Wow. It's holding together
quite nicely.
But the colours are fantastic.
Look at that.
Considering it's quite a lean meat,
goat,
that is succulent, it's juicy.
You've got the plantain that gives
you that lovely smoothness to it
and that tropical flavour as well,
but, together, it's really nice and
when you get that fruit,
that salsa as well,
it's spectacular.
It's absolutely wonderful.
Your grandma is a genius.
Get in! Yes, Nan!
What's your grandma's name?  Cynthia.
Will she come round to my house
and cook this?
Any time.
Just wanted to make my nan proud
cos, like, her food is crazy,
like, crazy good. Crazy good.
#Cynthia.
Sadly, I haven't felt like
this since week one.
I'll be so gutted.
I mean, desperately gutted
if I go home.
I'm very pleased with the comments,
I'm really, really pleased,
but, yeah, there's just...
..really worried that...
..that's not enough, really.
So we were worried about Julia and
Kate, coming into the Showstopper.
Are we still worried?
I thought Kate's looked amazing.
Love potato curry.
And for me, I think
she saved herself.
I thought Julia's was a bit untidy.
The pastry was a bit thick,
and raw in places.
Don't forget, she actually
did it in the tin.
Which, again, does that
fit the brief?
I think Stacey is in trouble.
Look at the pie. The flavours
were all over the place.
I think she struggled
on pastry week.
So who is in line for Star Baker?
I think Liam, Yan,
that's a good pastry.
And it's a great filling. And...
I think Sophie is still there.
Yeah.  The thing about Sophie
was her wonderful fruits of the
forest on top.  It did look good,
it looked very professional,
the crimping was great.
Liam just astonishes me,
week after week. He is... He's
something of a genius with flavour.
He's got an instinct for
what goes with whatever.
Can you see Sandi over the pie?
Oh, shut up.
Bakers, the person who is
Star Baker this week,
used the wisdom of their elders to
create a wonderful Showstopper.
Star Baker is...
..Liam.
So that leaves me
with the horrible job.
You are all amazing, you're down to
the last seven, it's incredible.
Somebody has to go home,
and it's really painful.
The person leaving
the tent this week is...
..Julia.
I am so sorry.
Sorry, sweetheart.
You did amazing,
you know that right?
You did incredible.
Well done, Jules. You did well.
You did very well.  Of course I will
carry on baking, that's my passion,
that's... I'm very lucky to find my
passion in something I enjoy doing
and I absolutely love
when I am only 21.
And, you know what?
There is only one place.
There is, there.
Well done.  Thank you.
Yeah.
Star Baker. I didn't think
I would ever get it.
Just over the moon.
Over the moon. Um, yeah.
It's like... Oh.
That's me done, I could go
next week now I've got Star Baker.
Mum, I got Star Baker.
Oh, my God.
Why are you crying?
Next time...
Under pressure, immense pressure.
A Mediterranean meltdown...
Oh.  ..in our first ever
Italian Week.
This is hot.
With a deep-fried
Sicilian signature...
That is heaven.
..a technical take away...
You look like a pizza.  I know.
..and the most demanding
pastry Showstopper...
So much pastry.
..the Bake Off has ever seen.
I'm going to faint.  These are
going to be "ugli-atelle".
Subtitles by Ericsson